[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
[Music]
all right and we are live lord cognito
here i love podcast lords of gaming.net
and who is this fine gentleman we have
the realm of tax quest today hi i'm
jeffrey matliff i'm doing pr for
and we are i'm going to show you the
planet of moana
let's get it man this is what it was i
was anticipating excited about our style
look cool let's get right into it let's
do it
and this little picture here that is
mui
and this becomes your your companion
friend and the two of you have to
go through this adventure together
figure out how to get off the planet and
figure out what's going on
in this planet become familiar with the
flora the fauna these strange robotic
sentinels you'll see more as we go
uh
loving the premise man off the bat i
mean
we've got to talk about this architect
right phenomenal
i guess in general like you know one of
the things that really captivated me to
it and that was just that that choice
right and see what's going on my first
question to you is we're talking about
what's up
again uh movie movie movie yeah what
said mao
i got fantasy
so very much as far as that was
talking is their dialogue or is it kind
of like a solid
tone where the game the environment's
only starting yeah
uh yeah there's no
there's no words okay
or it's a made-up language like you know
you you you'll call her you're calling
me
really making sounds is my question at
that point movie makes sounds but it's
not dialogue it's more like eco or you
know like yeah movies making animal
sounds that you're or if you play the
last guardian how you're calling the
creature but
you're not
let's go let's go see this world
wow
absolutely fun
checking it out moving around
seeing what's going on in this girl that
she just
crash landed and woke up now in this
world
yeah sorry i stopped to talk before i'll
try to multitask more don't worry
i got you though
all right
checking things out that's probably like
basic gameplay mechanics i'm seeing
obviously a run
a jump that you can climb onto things
okay
yeah so it starts out pretty simple
it'll get a little more complicated as
things as things move on but it is like
it is more about solving puzzles than
it's in an action game it's not
you're not going to be
doing a lot of
you're going to be bringing up the
inventory with the swords yeah exactly
it's going to be more like figuring out
what this is absolutely
so
as you can see when you step on it
it
extends yeah it extends so i need so we
need to
keep
keep moving
and then
i can color over
oh
okay
one thing off the back it really reminds
me of one of my favorite games of all
time it is called out of this world yep
i know it okay and it's made by one guy
and um
yeah it's eric
the legend the legend and i get
inspiration and i wanted to know as far
as like what were some of the
inspirations for a game like this for
you personally was it was it i mean for
the team was it like um american another
world or just you know also inside is a
game that comes to my mind you know
it's almost like that atmospheric
storytelling
and puzzles and things of that nature
yeah so i mean i can't speak for the
team because you know sadly they could
they couldn't be here they're halfway
possible
right now but i can say to me personally
i see a lot of inspiration from both yes
um out of this world another world
depending what territory you're in i
always forget what where it's called
where um yeah though they have a
different name too yeah
that's right so you can't get down there
so i gotta find another way
and you might notice that is doing
something unusual
yeah
you'll see it and those are some
yeah that's hinting at something to come
you know some sometimes rocks just move
in this world
the animation
is absolutely phenomenal
that's cool you can't you can't feel
that not
the controller yeah the way you pull
these off is you have to hit x and then
like
pull them off and just feels good all
right i got you yeah
and again i don't know if you know
what's the type of engine watch this
again what is this uh beauty or
yeah yeah
i had it written down so it says right
okay gotcha
let's get back to you all right
so
that way
yeah
yeah yeah i i
got something new before
oh so it's like a point okay got it okay
yeah got it man
oh this is the team this is the team
right now let's go
all right
there we go
[Music]
i
got a little over here
got it
um
yeah and you're about to see
let's see something
something spray
firefly something that's going to
require
do you record them with fireflies okay
what's going on here something is
going under that rock
you know i know the solution this puzzle
so i'm just doing it but if you're not
careful if mooi stops in the middle of
that thing it'll snap
yeah so basically that was more to
protect wood because those things would
would hurt and kill him yeah yeah muy
can run past him like if it's
it's not going to immediately kill muy
on contact but if maui stays there for
too long and then i'm going to assume if
muy dies the game is in an end state
yeah yeah then you get a game over in it
and it's never very punishing it just
brings you back to the last checkpoint
well thankfully for that yeah cause the
whole game is back in the day
so you'll see like movie can run past
it's not daddy yeah it's not immediately
gonna kill louie but if you're
figuring out the puzzle
um not sure what to do
so that was an advanced level move
right so i want to show you as much as
possible
yeah you know if it's friendly
out here
yes
my next
[Music]
huh
you know this is early in the game the
puzzles will get more complex as as it
progresses
this kind of teaches you the basic
mechanics how to how to guide muy right
oh i think we can even
yeah
just oh he's just like athletic
yeah
if you're going to crash landing on
alien planet
yeah this is this is what you want to
land next to
shout out to movie
let's do this thing okay
okay okay now it's getting interesting
we got a lot of this oh wait um
so this has got a cord that is
preventing me or moving it further
so
i need to find a way to get rid of that
yes
this is
[Music]
there's this thing there i think
there might be something up here
or there
but i wanted to check
check the environment
all right cut this
yeah we chewed through it
much like real cats with all of our
electronics
yes
insulation
that would have been a dangerous bite
it's got some kick to it yes
looking at
me
i think we're about to see a little a
little more of this unique planet
adventuring
that's right i love it
i just love the different layers of
foliage that they have but yeah what
were you saying no i mean that looks
absolutely phenomenal i mean my thing is
as far as do we know as far as like
gameplay hours what are we looking at
for an adventure like
yeah so
oh we gotta hide the grass first yeah
that's gotta hide in grass those are
like zelda sentimentals i don't want no
problems with those
time to bring
over oh but we're really detecting oh no
i was hoping that once it got in the
grass that the thing was struck but i i
was being too impatient oh so yeah in
terms of hours you know it's it's gonna
to range you know of course based on
you know how fast
but i would say
um i'd say probably between six to ten
hours so like
pretty long for this kind of game
but you know not super long if we're
talking about uh
yeah if we're talking about like yeah
a lot of this is very positive depending
on the consent how quickly you can solve
the folks what i thought is interesting
is that
you know most of things you know it's
you're the main character but
you have to protect lulu as well because
it's movie spotted in this situation
like i said it's an end mechanic for
both of you
oh yeah i
accidentally told maui
[Music]
yeah it has that thing to show you the
movie is
he has to kind of jazz himself up before
he jumps very cool
it does give the sense of truly having a
pet you know in an environment
and i do like that as you point out the
wave that you don't have to stop and
tell them to come you can just do it as
you go
here's where
yeah there's something going on with
these
things
[Music]
headphones right now because it would
have been hard to incorporate well
that's as far as we're going to go but
look
first of all the style is absolutely
fantastic you know very charming very
like a lot a lot of a lot of heart team
you could tell it's part of the team how
big is the team do we know in general as
far as we're talking about it but at
that point i'm actually not sure
well i want to say like
this
this genre i don't see represented a lot
and it's really cool to see it kind of
come back and obviously we saw the deal
with xbox game pass and stuff like that
so again it's going to be a day one game
day one game pass game i think it's
really cool to get a new generation of
gamers that grew up with the games that
we me and you grew up with the another
world but there's a whole generation
that really don't haven't experienced
that with environmental storytelling and
puzzle solving and i think that's really
cool yeah we've seen that like a little
with like limbo and inside but those
aren't much you know darker horror games
this is a little lighter but it still
has darkness too and i mean you saw what
happened to movies
yeah
no settles on playing so no so planet a
lot and how small how
uh it's spring 2023 spring 2023 pc and
xbox
game pass day one an absolute pleasure
all right highly anticipated games i'll
be looking forward to you guys as you
get closer to the release planet of
london laura cognito here welcome
gaming.net
[Music]
welcome
to the iron lord's pocket